Outbreak: index-sw-9a4c43b4b4778e7d1ca619eaaf5ac1db.js
Alexander Pope
ALEXANDER: All right.
[Applause]
There we are.
Do we have some music?
There we go.
Hello, welcome to the last Side Track event.
My name is Alexander Pope and I'm really excited
to be here today to share this story with
all of you.
[spooky music]
It's a scary story so I hope nobody has a
weak stomach, and like the scariest stories,
it's all true.
Mostly.
I'm going to try something here.
I am going to try and actually say the title
of the talk.
This is Outbreak: index-sw-9a4c43b4b4778e7d1ca619eaaf5ac1db.js.
[Cheering]
If this wasn't attached to my head, I would
just drop the mic and go, but I have a story
to tell and here we go.
In the corner of a functional though charmless
open office, Alexander sits at his desk staring
intently
at the screen.
A phone rings in the background, momentarily
disrupting the early morning stillness.
[Inaudible announcement]
The following morning, in a cramped meeting
room, Alexander enthusiastically sketches
on a wall-mounted white board.
[Inaudible film]
>> Alexander, we hope you are aware ... [inaudible]
something is broken.
Fix it and ship it.
Just change something.
Within 24 hours at least.
[inaudible].
ALEXANDER: Days later, Alexander hurries,
cleans up commits while rebasing a git merge
for release.
The desk is littered with disposable coffee
cups.
[Inaudible film]
>> Alexander, have
you forgotten about something?
ALEXANDER: Several weeks passed.
In the quiet of a darkened living room Alexander
anxiously scans error logs.
Notification alerts pierce
the silence.
>> Function ... I don't get it.
How can that all be ... this specification
is unstable, as you are well aware.
>> Shut up.
Focus.
ALEXANDER: One week later, back at the office,
Alexander puzzles over the latest error logs.
>> That's weird.
... it's just not possible.
ALEXANDER: More
weeks pass.
Visibly tired and distraught, Alexander slumps
over his computer at
the dinner table.
A baby cries in
the background.
>> This is starting to freak me out [inaudible]
...
>> Don't be ridiculous, in a year or two ... [inaudible
from film] ...
ALEXANDER: Ooh!
That
gives me chills every time I think about it.
Permanently installed, that is a horror story.
You know, there's something strangely compelling
about a disaster story.
Sometimes it's the disaster as an act of God,
other times it's man-made but the best of
them have this in common: the central characters
are faced with difficult, sometimes impossible
moral dilemmas.
As viewers we ask ourselves how we would behave
in similar circumstances.
Could we handle the pressure?
Would we make the same choices?
Would we do the right thing?
Some of my favourite disaster stories are
about epidemics, or disease outbreaks that
threaten humanity: think Night of the Living
Dead, 28 Days Later, 12 Monkeys, Children
of Men, and many others.
Many of these stories and the entire zombie
genre in fact were inspired by the book I
Am Legend by Richard Matheson.
The book has been adapted three times for
the big screen and my favourite version is
The Omega Man from 1971 starring Charlton
Heston.
I love it because it is just so 70s.
And Charlton Heston just can't stop delivering
cheesy one-liners, no matter what happens
to him.
[Inaudible film]
ALEXANDER: The antagonists in this version
are more human than the vampires and zombies
of the others, and I like that this cult of
albino mutants spends all of its time raging
against the science and technology that they
blame for their fate.
In most zombie stories they don't plan on
turning people into zombies, it just sort
of happens by accident and it's usually because
technology goes a little bit out of control.
Now, as I struggled against my own mob of
zombie service workers I realised that there
is a real risk of triggering technological
backlash.
Now, as web developers we are constantly tempted
to throw more and more technology at the problem
but if we aren't careful we might end up pissing
off our users, making things that are slow,
annoying, inefficient, insecure, or even just
full of bugs.
It really risks alienating the people we are
trying to make happy.
Now, for the next 11.5 minutes things are
going to get a little serious.
Not like, "Oh my God, this is serious!" kind
of serious, but more like the grown-up kind
of serious.
There will be a lot of information that may
or may not be relevant to you now, but don't
worry, if one day you find out you need it
you can always find it on GitHub.
Before we first go too deep, just in case
some of you are wondering what the hell a
service worker actually is, here are the basics.
A service worker is a script installed via
a web page that runs in the background.
It gives you the power to control asset caching,
to handle requests from pages and workers
when offline, and to respond to incoming push
notifications.
Service worker is a type of worker, so it
doesn't have access to the DOM, AJAX or local
storage but it does have post message for
communicating with clients, fetch for accessing
the network and IndexedDB for storage.
Service worker has a life cycle which starts
with registration, when the file is downloaded
and executed; it then enters the installation
phase when the install event is triggered,
and if there is already an older version installed
and it's actively controlling clients, the
service worker enters what's called the waiting
phase until all clients have disconnected.
When it's safe to start controlling new clients
the activate event is triggered and the service
worker enters the activation phase.
Finally, when the activation phase is over,
the service worker is known as running, and
able respond to client network requests via
the fetch event handler.
Now, service worker also has new toys including
a cache API for storing network requests and
responses, a clients API for managing connective
clients, which are pages and workers, and
a push API for managing push notifications
from remote servers.
So with that out of the way we can get down
to business.
How do we avoid the next zombie apocalypse?
Or here are some things I wish I had known
before I started with service worker.
Rule number 1, in no particular order, understand
how promises work but don't use them, use
async/await if you can instead.
Using async/await can really help make things
more legible.
Although very few browsers support native
async/await, it's just syntactic sugar over
generators and promises, and every one that
supports service worker will also support
async/await.
Using Babel with the async-to-generator plugin
will do the transformation for you but be
aware that this code cannot be uglified - you
should use Babili which is another plugin
for Babel that you can use for minification
instead.
Two, don't use while the page is loading.
Wait for the window on load event or some
other signal before registering.
Rule number three: know your dependencies.
During the installation phase, passing a promise
to event.waituntil will delay service worker
activation until it's resolved.
However, if it's rejected, the service worker
will be thrown away and marked redundant.
Now, since the installation phase is when
you want to pre-cache all your assets, any
asset that fails to load will cause a rejection.
In this sense, you can think of pre-cached
assets as hard dependencies, so you should
beware.
Rule number 4: cache smarter.
When upgrading a service worker, it's common
practice to pre-cache assets in a new, uniquely
named cache before deleting any old caches
during the activation phase.
Now, in most cases this is a really good approach
but if you release very often you can avoid
wasting storage and bandwidth by only fetching
new assets and then recycling the old ones.
Now you can first create more than one cache
to separate versioned assets from those that
won't change, and copy versioned assets from
the old cache if they already exist.
Now, obviously this is not as neat as cache
at all, but it is much more efficient.
Rule number 5: avoid forcing activation for
major changes.
Forcing activation after an update can break
already connected clients if the new service
worker is very different from the old version.
So you can avoid calling self-.skipWaiting
after a major change and consider actually
prompting the user to trigger a manual refresh,
and that way there won't be any breakage.
Rule number 6, use a library for messaging.
Sending messages between a service worker
and its clients is actually kind of weird.
The API is a bit hard to work with but using
a library like Swivel makes it a lot easier.
Number 7: never rename the service worker
file.
Once the service worker has been installed
and activated, it will need to be updated,
of course, but often we cache the HTML file
that triggers the registration so it would
be difficult to install a new service worker
if it had a new name from that HTML file.
So you can avoid this chicken and egg problem
by making sure that the service worker script
file name is never unique, it's always the
same.
Along with that, rule number 8: you have to
set correct cache headers because, of course,
if the service worker script file names are
static and the browser fetches the script
through the browser cache before going to
the network you will need to correctly set
cache control headers to prevent the browser
from caching outdated versions.
As a precaution, to avoid accidentally installing
a service worker for days, weeks or months,
caches will be bypassed if the script is older
than 24 hours, regardless of what you set.
Now, cash invalidation is always tricky as
we know, so in the future browsers will be
using cache busting always by default to ensure
that the service worker script files are always
up-to-date.
Rule number 9: invalidate your service worker
when updated.
The service worker will be updated if it is
byte different from previous versions.
Now, a simple pattern you can use to treat
the service worker as a boot loader by using
import scripts and version dependencies, and
that's all you have to have in your service
worker file.
Rule number 10: add a feature flag or kill
switch.
This one is important.
Having an easy way to disable existing service
workers is a life saver really.
Add a feature flag to control on registration.
Keep a no op service worker handy in case
you have to have a quick deploy, or even better,
have a service worker phone home to check
its version then force an update if it's outdated.
Rule number 11: don't cache bad responses.
You should always check the ok property of
the response object returned from a fetch
call before you add it to your cache because
HTTP response codes, they don't cause the
promise to reject.
So you have to manually check.
Rule 12: don't store global state.
Storing global state in a service worker is
really bad.
Bad idea.
Because code outside of the event handlers,
like install, activate and fetch, they run
each time the service worker is started, but
the service worker is stopped and started
many times over its lifetime as the - yes,
the device manages battery and other resources,
so it's really important not to store global
state because it will be destroyed at unexpected
times.
Rule number 13: guard against missing APIs.
A number of API methods were added in later
browser versions, so it's wise to test whether
they exist before calling them.
The following methods were added in later
versions of Chrome, for example, after service
worker was launched.
Rule number 14, this is an important one too:
test your service worker.
Now, because of the installation life cycle
and the unique environment that they run in,
service workers are really difficult to test.
As always, running tests in real browsers
with real code is going to give you the most
realistic results but unfortunately there
aren't yet any good tools to help with browser
tests.
But the methodology well laid out in this
article by Matt Gaunt of Google.
Highly recommended.
Now, automating browser tests comes with its
own set of challenges as some of you will
know so it's best to test as much as possible.
Fortunately there are some tools available
to easily mock and test service worker environment.
As part of their service workers tool chain
Pinterest has developed helper functions and
a mock you can use to make the Node.js global
look more like a service worker.
I've also released a project called sw-test-env
and it's a little more thorough mock of the
service worker environment and allows you
to run scripts in an isolated sandboxed context.
With it, you can inspect the properties of
the service worker scope, manually trigger
events, post message between clients and service
worker instances, use import scripts, fetch
real or mocked data, use indexedDB storage
and require modules from inside your service
worker file without a build script.
Now, here is an example from one of the unit
tests I wrote for my slides because I write
tests for my slides.
First, we load the service worker file; then
we create a populate an old version of the
cache.
Then we trigger the install phase; and finally
we read from the cache to verify the old version
has in fact been recycled.
Now, I think it could be a really useful tool
so if you get the chance, take a look and
let me know what you think.
Finally, rule number 15: use a service worker
generator tool.
If you don't want to get your hands dirty
with all these details, you can use one of
several service worker generator tools.
There are lots of good ones out there.
But you should still write tests.
So, now that we are educated, you might be
wondering what happened.
What was the recipe for this disaster?
Simply, it was one part ignorance, one part
stupidity and one part mystery.
Now, we know that versions of Chrome before
46 didn't support cache at all.
So any client missing that API should have
caused the promise return to the install event
to reject with a syntax error.
Undefined as not a function.
Unfortunately a catch was also added to the
promised chain in order to report install
errors, but the error was never thrown further
up the chain.
And the service worker was installed instead
of thrown away.
That explains how some clients became infected
with a broken service worker, and based on
the number of errors reported it's clear that
most of the infected were soon cured, but
it's still a mystery to me as to why or how
a small number became permanently cursed.
Now, even after trying to install an empty
service worker, then eventually a kill switch
to unregister it completely, that broken file
still haunts me and probably will until every
one of those devices is retired.
[Laughter]
Now, even if the details are lost on you,
I hope I've made my case that service worker
is a complex beast.
It is awesome, but it's kind of awesome like
the way a chainsaw is awesome.
[Laughter]
It's really powerful, and really easy to lose
a hand, a foot, maybe some toes.
But don't be afraid because a lot of people
use chainsaws every day without spilling blood.
They take precautions, they dress for the
job and they read the instructions.
Now that I know more, now that I have some
tools for testing, I'm ready to get back into
the lab and I hope that everyone here is also
ready because service worker really is the
best thing since AJAX and I know everyone
remembers how that turned out.
So thank you and remember to kill your bugs
and zombies but not your dreams.
Thank you.
[Applause]
REMY: Awesome stuff.
Yes, really, really good.